Speaker 2: , I have a we're going to look at a
couple of videos from attendees at the Youngstown,
Ohio Trump rally over the weekend. This was the
rally at which Donald Trump was supposedly going
to support JD Vance, although he at one point made
fun of JD Vance. But that doesn't really matter.
Let's look at some of the videos of people who
went. This one is unbelievable. There is a woman
who is thrilled that Trump called out to
her, even though Trump referred to her as
this guy. This especially with
everything that's going on right now.
With Trump's transphobia and the resurgence of
transphobia among the right. Something about this
video just cracks me up. Check this out.
Speaker 1: But what about.
Speaker 3: This wonderful present? Talk
to me beforehand or at anything and ask
Howard. I loved him. He stopped and he said, I
love you, too. And then he thought he said, This
guy says he loves me, and I swear I'm a woman.
Speaker 1:
Oh, is it?
Speaker 2: All of these events are
completely beyond parody. Mean. It's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable. And it's funny because
these folks love to say Democrats and the left,
you don't know what a woman is. You can't identify
a woman. It's so obvious. What's a woman? What's
a man who's a woman? Who's a man? And then now
it's all a big joke that Trump thought this woman
was a man. I guess some Republicans struggle with
that as well, it seems. And it sort of puts into
particular perspective these absurd transphobic
anecdotes that Donald Trump now regularly tells
at his rallies. Another interview that took
place with a rally attendee was actually with a
January six defended Mickey Larsen, known as the Q
Patriot, I guess, was interviewed by Donald
Trump's attorney, Christina Bobb, who is also
an anchor on right side broadcasting. I mean,
every detail is absurd. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: And I served error bars for 21 years.
I'm a January six defendant. Can we say that?
And I wrote a phone call. We're ready to have
a copy. I'll give to you. That sounds great.
You look fantastic. What prompted the outfit?
I started this after the election was stolen.
Speaker 2: Actually, by the way. So the woman
is dressed with. I can't even describe it. She
seems to have like a tentacle wig of red, white
and blue, and then like a crazy glitter hat. And
it just it's an insane outfit. And it's funny
because it's like, what made you start dressing
like this? Well, when they stole the election
from Trump, I started dressing like a lunatic. Oh,
that makes sense. A Halloween costume.
Speaker 3: And I was in Arizona doing a
Patriot Party out there, and my costume
was in Abilene, Texas. So I was like,
I need to find a reason to wear it. So the
first time I wore was November of 2021.
A market car rally. And then it just became
my thing and I went to all the events. Well,
it is great. You look fantastic. It's energizing.
I think people are excited. I'm going to bring it
over here to Brian, who's got an announcement.
Speaker 2: Yeah, they're going to try to get
it. Looked like Christina Bobb actually got a
signal from someone off camera to get away from
that. And then this is the last this is really,
really funny. You know how it's a very it's like a
point of pride at some of these rallies to say you
came from really far away. It really just proves
your cult, this credentials. But they love to say,
oh, I drove 5 hours, 10 hours, whatever a woman
explains. She drove 5 hours to the Trump rally and
the interviewer tries to push on her that the gas
prices were probably crazy. And the woman admits,
you know, the gas prices really weren't that bad.
Unidentified: And you're in Indiana. How long was.
Speaker 3: Too bad, but I'm sure that gas prices
were bad. You know what's too bad.
Speaker 2:
For, what, a year and a half? They've been saying
Joe Biden's gas prices are destroying the country.
And this moment, guys, you know, we've came
from 5 hours away. Really, we didn't really
pay that much. Gas prices were actually quite
reasonable. Every little detail of this cult is
putting SNL out of business. I mean, you
can't really parody this. And then the
last component of this. The last component of
this, yes. Is Mike Pillow. Let's go to that next